moi en première année de prépa hec et
j'étais au fond de la classe
en culture générale j'étais très calme
je ne faisais pas le bordel je ne disais
pas un mot j'étais très concentré parce
que je faisais des maths
la première année de prépa hec je la
connais bien parce que je suis passé par
là il ya maintenant plus de dix ans mais
surtout parce que ça fait aussi plus de
dix ans que je prépare des élèves de
prépa hec aux épreuves de culture
générale des concours des écoles de
commerce chaque année plusieurs milliers
d'élèves de prépa hec s'inscrivent sur
mille idées de culture générale et
beaucoup m'écrivent donc je connais bien
leur problème
leur défi ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marche pas pour eux une chose qu'ils
font particulièrement mal c'est
identifier leurs objectifs si vous êtes
en première année de prépa âge c'est
qu'ils doivent être vos objectifs en
culture générale
pour faire simple je vous conseille d'en
viser seulement deux premiers objectifs
que vos notes dans culture générale vous
permettent de passer en deuxième année
et secondes
objectif améliorer votre compétence dans
les différentes épreuves de culture
générale des concours en vue de l'année
prochaine
vous le savez certainement déjà mais une
compétence crucial en culture générale
c'est la méthodologie de la dissertation
et bien j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo comme
c'est un cours par email vous pourrez le
découvrir après la vidéo ou dans les
prochains jours je retourne à nos
moutons je vais vous révéler les trois
clés pour travailler efficacement la
culture générale en première année de
prépa hec
regardez attentivement cette vidéo et
vous atteindrez vos deux objectifs en
économisant beaucoup de temps
je me souviens qu'en première année le
prof a passé 90 % du temps à débiter son
cours c'était long digressif confus au
point que les élèves se sont révoltés
deux fois au cours de l'année alors je
ne vous dérange pas si un peu quand même
quel est le problème avec cette manière
de faire on peut dire qu'il ya plusieurs
problèmes
mais le problème principal c'est l'excès
d'information à quoi est ce que ça peut
bien vous servir un court 2 300 pages
vous allez apprendre comment vous
n'aurez jamais le temps de la prendre et
même si vous arrivez à la prendre
entièrement vous serez handicapés pour
les épreuves des dissertations parce que
vous aurez trop d'informations à traiter
dans un court laps de temps vous avez
déjà utilisé un disque dur qui est plein
à craquer et bien c'est pareil
vous avez beaucoup d'informations mais
vous ne pouvez pas utiliser toute cette
information parce que le disque dur ram
voici donc la solution vous devez
limiter la quantité d'informations à
assimiler ça ne sert à rien de noter
tout ce que dit le prof
puisque vous n'aurez même pas le temps
de tout relire non vous devez simplement
noté l'essentiel le noter dans un format
facile à relire et puis le relis
régulièrement
j'ai trois conseils pratiques à vous
donner premièrement noté maximum un
recto parcours vous verrez qu'à la fin
de l'année ça fera déjà beaucoup
deuxièmement noté exclusivement sous
forme de boulettes poynt éléments
d'information par éléments d'information
ça va vous forcer à clarifier
l'information donc vos notes seront plus
faciles à relire troisième et dernier
conseil prenez 30 minutes à une heure
par semaine pour relire attentivement
vos notes plutôt que de réviser toute la
nuit avant le ds relisez l'essentiel au
moins une fois par semaine ça sera
suffisant
ça y est j'en ai terminé avec la
première clé on passe à la deuxième
j'ai déjà dit dans d'autres vidéos
ce n'est pas en prépa hec que j'ai
appris à faire une dissertation notre
propre ne nous a pas expliqué encore
moins montrer comment faire une
dissertation du coup quel est le
problème est bien plein d'élèves de
prépa hec
je pense même la grande majorité
finissent la première année sans
maîtriser la méthodologie de la
dissertation et je voulais déjà dit
c'était aussi mon cas
quelle est la solution à l'époque où
j'étais en prépa hec en 2005 et on ne
veut pas mais maintenant vous pouvez
vous inscrire à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo c'est un
court simple et pratique pour gagner des
points rapidement et des dizaines de
milliers d'élèves l'ont déjà suivi
inscrivez-vous si ce n'est pas déjà fait
et vous m'en direz des nouvelles
alors vous l'avez peut-être déjà reçu
donc je vais vous donner deux conseils
supplémentaires premier conseil une fois
que vous aurez assimilés mon cours de
méthodologie
entraînez-vous en traitant un maximum de
sujets isolé vous coupez les
distractions et prenez une heure une
heure et demie pour traiter un sujet et
élaborer le plan détaillé
si vous le faites une ou deux fois par
semaine vous allez devenir très fort en
dissertation second conseil fait
corriger vos plans détaillés je pense
que votre prof acceptera mais vous
pouvez aussi demander à vos amis de vous
donner leur avis et si vous êtes membre
de ma formation avancée à la
méthodologie de la dissertation
vous savez que je corrige tout ce que
vous m'envoyez petite précision cette
deuxième clé vaut non seulement pour la
dissertation mais aussi pour la
contraction est pour la synthèse
l'enjeu est le même apprenez une méthode
et entraînez-vous régulièrement à la
mettre en pratique
allez il est temps de passer à la
troisième et dernière clé
la troisième et dernière clé concerne le
lit trois exercices de culture générale
la dissertation la contraction est la
synthèse vous l'avez deviné quel point
c'est de l'expression écrite dont je
vais vous parler
quel est le problème avec l'expression
écrite le problème et c'est que la
plupart des profs n'en parle même pas
alors que c'est crucial
l'expression écrite est crucial en prépa
hec parce que si vous écrivez mal vous
partez avec un gros handicap tandis que
si vous écrivez bien vous avez au
contraire un avantage injuste et ce
n'est pas vrai uniquement pour les
exercices de culture générale c'est vrai
pour toutes les matières littéraires
vous croyez vraiment que les correcteurs
de géopolitique d'économie ou de langues
n'ont rien à faire de la qualité de
votre style bien sûr que non bon une
fois qu'on a pris conscience de
l'importance du style quelle est la
solution
je vous la dévoile dans une autre vidéo
intitulée dissertation les trois secrets
pour améliorer son style je vous
explique les caractéristiques précises
du style qui séduit les correcteurs des
concours et je vous révèle des
techniques et des exercices précis pour
acquérir ce style séduisant vous
trouverez facilement la vidéo sur cette
chaîne youtube
regardez-la attentivement et vous
connaîtrez la troisième clé pour
travailler efficacement la culture
générale en première année de prépa hec
voici en résumé les trois clés pour
travailler efficacement la culture
générale en premier limiter la quantité
d'informations à ingérer cette première
clé concerne uniquement la dissertation
vous l'avez compris deuxième clé
acquérir une méthode et s'entraîner à la
mettre en pratique cette deuxième clé
concerne l'ic3 exercice la dissertation
la contraction est la synthèse troisième
et dernière clé améliorer votre
expression écrite
si vous vous concentrez sur ces trois
clés non seulement vous aurez une bonne
note en culture générale pour passer en
deuxième année
mais en plus vous serez déjà bien
préparer pour les épreuves des concours
de l'année prochaine je vous ai déjà dit
mais je le répète au cas où vous devez
maîtriser la méthodologie de la
dissertation donc
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologies soient en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit en cliquant sur
celui qui est dans la description de
cette vidéo
moi j'ai fait pas mal d'erreurs en
première une prépa hec
donc j'espère vraiment que cette vidéo
vous sera utile je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote qui
dort là bas et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale
rappelez vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour travailler
efficacement la culture générale en
première année de prépa hec
[Musique]